Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
Okay.
So we are picking back up again with a Spiderman part two.
And this week we're going to kind of run through a whole bunch of Spider-Man
related content,
mostly because of the fact that the new Spider-Man games coming out,
we kind of want to be done in time for all of that stuff. But, um,
and this one we pick up with part two right now, again,
for those of you guys who are just joining us here,
Spider-Man is the first time that Peter Parker from the main Marvel universe
meets miles Morales, the new Spider-Man in the ultimate universe, right?
This is a big deal. When it first came out.
Now we ended up having this happening by way of the fact that, uh,
Mysteria had basically managed to create some kind of interdimensional portal.
And the result was that when Peter Parker came upon it and he ended up finding
Mysterio, Peter Parker ended up being thrown through, right.
He was kind of sucked through more than anything else.
But Peter Parker passed through it ended up in the ultimate universe.
What this does is it wakes up with Mysterio in the aftermath of that. Now,
as soon as the material comes to his immediate response is really bro,
he's incredibly off, right? Because he's just like, this is the worst thing.
Now it's not like super complicated or anything.
That's one of the great things about Brian,
Michael Bendis when he was writing really ultimate Spider-Man and miles Morales,
Spiderman. I always say Bennet's is better when he's writing kids are teenagers.
When it comes to adults, he's not that good, but with kids or teenagers,
he's amazing. Right? So riding miles, Morales, he was super good at it.
But the idea behind this is that from mysterious perspective,
he does not want to run into another situation where Peter Parker exists,
but him basically stumbling across the ultimate universe was a universe where
Peter Parker Spider-Man didn't really exist.
Peter Parker had never heard of Mysterio. And so with him, you know,
really presuming that miles Morales, the,
that he knew miles existed there miles could be somebody he could overcome
pretty, pretty quickly, right? Because by and large,
when it comes to Marvel comics, villains from the,
from the main Marvel universe are usually more powerful from villain of the
villains, from the ultimate universe and even main characters themselves,
even somebody like the Phoenix force or like Thor or Loki,
they're really powerful characters in relation to their, uh,
to their ultimate universe counterparts because the ultimate universe was
designed to be more toned down and realistic, even in the realm of comic books,
if you're writing a character and really a series of stories that exist as close
as you can get to the real world,
you probably don't want to really see these wild flights of fantasy when it
comes to ridiculous level of, uh, levels of power, right?
Like the marquee of death, different things like that.
But the whole idea here is that what you end up having is mysterious,
who basically kind of brings out this kind of avatar.
And this is basically a version of himself,
kind of a robotic version of himself that can go into the ultimate universe in a
stet, right? Because if you're Mysterio,
you don't want to get yourself killed going into the ultimate universe.
You send a robot in your place. And so switching over to Peter and miles,
this is one of the interesting things here, albeit a little strange.
And the reason why is because initially Peter doesn't know what to make of miles
and miles doesn't know what to make of Peter, right?
He's like one of the worlds going on and Peter hasn't figured out that he's in
the ultimate universe because he doesn't know what the ultimate union of a
universe is. He just knows he's in some other place. Right.
And seemingly picking up pretty quickly on the fact that he's in some kind of an
alternate dimension. And so because of this, there's a, you know,
kind of fight that starts to break out between Peter and miles' because Peter is
like, okay, you're freaking me out. Right?
Because they keep going back and forth, right. Peter's like,
what's the deal here. Miles is like, you tell me. And Peter's like,
is it a clone thing? And he's like, what's a clone thing. He was like,
you tell me, he's like, I thought it was some kind of Nick fury test.
Isn't a Nick fury test. And miles was like, you tell me. And it's like,
you know, just kind of going back and forth. Right. So Peter gets frustrated,
gets a little, uh, it gets a little tough and, uh, ends up attacking miles,
right. Is up going after miles but miles for his part immediately Dodges,
Spiderman, weapon. Right? And so from there,
what you end up getting is this really interesting situation where miles is able
to Bob and weave and duck all of Spider-Man's attacks and then counter
proportionally. Now this is where things get a little wonky, right?
This is where things get a little, I don't know how I feel about that, right?
Because keep in mind,
Myles has not been formally trained by anybody at shield yet. Right.
And anybody in this risk, Elliot by Nick theory or any of those guys.
And so he is still in a lot of ways flying by the seat of his pants.
And so the fact that we're kind of getting this version of miles,
who over his time in being Spider-Man is able to go toe to toe with Peter
Parker.
Who's been playing this role for a very long time and not only go toe to toe
manage the Dodges attacks and then shock him is a little bit stunning here,
but no pun intended. There's a little bit stunning here.
But the funny thing about this too, is we can also kind of play into it,
into it from Peter's perspective that Peter is not fighting to like beat the
crap out of miles. Right. He's not looking to like overcome miles.
He's looking to kind of subdue him, everything else. Right.
Probably web him up or something like that.
If Peter were fighting miles in the same vein that he was fighting,
somebody like rhino or like Dr. Octopus or somebody like that,
the fight probably would have gone a much different way.
And it would have been over much, much faster.
The reality is which way this fight would have gone.
Depends on which character you like more, that's basically what it is. Right.
If you're a fan of miles, you're like, yo of course,
miles can overcome Peter Parker. If you don't believe me,
just ask me and I'll tell you, but if you're a fan of Peter Parker,
it's the exact same thing. Right. I was like, no,
Peter Parker definitely could've gotten the upper hand on miles. Right. I mean,
I know because I'm right, right. I mean, that's, that's kind of how we,
it's kinda good fans get, we need no other evidence than our own opinion.
And that's basically it. Now,
the funny thing is miles actually goes to take the mask off Peter,
which miles should know by now is kind of a no-no,
that's just something that you don't do. And that leads to Peter,
basically reacting, you know,
waking up and then kicking miles off the ledge of the building. Right.
And then from there Peter's like, dude, I think I just.
Killed this kid.
I think I just did this kid in, uh, I do not need that on my conscious, right.
I do not need this on my conscious. Now unbeknownst to him, of course,
miles has initiated his invisibility power, but nonetheless,
Peter's just kind of like, uh, okay. I think I killed this kid. This was a,
this is a problem. We got to find this kid. Right. And then miles pops back up,
gets the upper hand on Peter kicks him.
And then of course Peter ends up kind of spinning some wedding outs.
And then from there he chooses webbing into miles' mask and yanks his mask off.
Right. And that's what he's kind of like, alright,
it's time for you to come clean. Right? Like how are you Spiderman?
What's going on here? Like, like give me all the skinny,
give me all the information on the response of miles.
If you have to give me my mask back, right?
Like anybody out here could see that I'm Spiderman and I have to keep my family
and my identity protected, like, give me my mask back.
Now you would expect Peter to respond and say, yeah,
I kind of understand where you're coming from. That's kind of my thing too.
But desperate times call for desperate measures and Peter needs information.
The problem with this is he didn't really understand why miles got the upper
hand on him the first time.
And so he didn't really even think about the venom blast this time,
which miles uses channels that into the end of the webbing and then takes out
Peter it's genius.
And that was one of the cool things that made miles so interesting in the early
comics is when you were reading his character,
you could actually watch him become a biter,
a better Spider-Man as you were reading the comics.
And so with every single story arc that you read,
he was a better version of Spider-Man at the end of that story than he was
before he started the story. But it was really, really cool.
But with regards to Peter, what you end up getting here is a,
is miles basically using Peter's web shooters, right. To kind of swing them,
you know, down to down on the ground.
And they kind of get them onto a roof and they get them to safety.
And when they collapse, right,
he ends up taking the mask off Peter and he realizes, Oh my God,
this is Peter Parker. Now for him,
he doesn't know this is Peter from the Marvel universe,
from the main Marvel universe. Right.
He thinks just like Peter Parker returned from his universe. So he's like,
I have no idea what I do here. Right.
And that's what he kind of looks over to the triskelion and Peter Parker is
taken to the shield headquarters, right? From there, he meets with Nick fury.
Now most of the guys who read the ultimate universe,
no two things about Nick fury.
The first one is that he was based on Samuel Jackson. Right. And in fact,
Samuel Jackson actually threatened to Sue Marvel,
but they ended up letting him play the role of Nick fury in the MCU.
So the lawsuit never happened. Right. That's why we got Samuel Jackson,
Nick fury. But the other thing about this is that Nick fury is highly skeptical.
Right? He is a super suspicious guy. And so when he starts asking questions,
when he starts asking him like, well,
at least when we first do them as Peter and Peter's like, like, do you know me?
And he's like, I know the name, you know? And it's that kind of a thing.
He started the two of them start talking to each other.
And it's kind of a cool bit of a conversation here. Right.
Because Peter even makes reference to the fact that like, I know your eyepatch,
but it's, it's, it's one of these little, these little tidbit things.
But when he asks him like, you know, are you Peter Parker? It's like, well,
it's not that straightforward. And I was like, okay, well then give me a,
give me an answer. Like give me this one hypothetical answer that you have.
And Peter basically reiterate this whole fight with Mysterio,
then passing through the portal and the Indigo here and all that kind of stuff.
And Nick curious, kind of like, huh, okay. I mean,
I could probably buy that story. It's so farfetched. It might just be true.
Right. It's just, it's one of those things.
So we just kind of ended up getting Peter credibility here.
Now the reality of this is that Bendis does this just for the sake of keeping
the story moving forward under any other comic in the ultimate universe,
Nick fury would be like, no, I'm not buying that.
You're going to stay in this cell until you tell me what's actually going on.
And he would legitimately leave him there. Leak-free would've done that. If you,
if you,
if you said that this happened in the Ultimate's and it was anybody else besides
Spiderman,
if it was ultimate or like the ultimate fantastic four or the ultimate X-Men
Nick fury will be like, no, man, I'm not buying into that. That nonsense,
that crazy malarkey not buying into that, any of that stuff. Right.
So he would just leave him there,
but Bendis does this for the sake of keeping the story moving forward.
What he ends up doing is basically handing Peter over to miles and say, okay,
it's your all's job to go do your own thing, right?
Your all's job to get this whole thing sorted out and find out what's going on.
And so what Peter does is by virtue of what Nick fury told him,
the way that miles is acting, that kind of thing,
he starts to put two and two together.
And so what he does is he really kind of asks the big question,
like tell me kid in this universe is Peter Parker dead, right?
Is Peter Parker not alive here anymore?
And this was kind of nuts is because before miles can really give them an answer
and explain everything.
Both of them are shot through the helicopter by this avatar of Mysterio.
And in turn miles basically saves both of them and then kind of takes both guys
or really takes him in the pilot down to their safety. Right.
But basically Mysterio is here and starts launching his attack against, uh,
against Peter and miles. So this is when we go from miles Morales,
meeting Peter Parker to miles fighting Peter to miles and Peter teaming up.
So with that being said, guys, we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to comments,
explain to make sure you guys have the sub button to become part of the Rob
core. If you guys enjoyed this video, make sure you drop a,
like now we'll catch you all later, Bruce.
[Inaudible].